[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a una semana en el
mundo el programa de France 24 en el que
los periodistas son los invitados y
conversamos de una manera más
distensionada sobre algunos de los
hechos más destacados de la semana para
conversar sobre los temas que hemos
seleccionado para el programa de hoy
saludamos en Madrid en España a Roberto
macedonio Roberto Bienvenido al programa
Qué tal termina usted en la semana
qué tal Santiago cansado verdad porque
los viernes después de una semana con
tanta actualidad pues uno tiene
demasiadas cosas en la cabeza Así que
vamos a ordenarlas vamos a intentar
ordenar algunos de los hechos destacados
de la semana saludo también en la ciudad
de leeds en el Reino Unido está con
nosotros Camilo Tamayo Camilo bienvenido
y cómo termina usted su semana
bueno Muy buenas tardes para ustedes
Santiago
pues terminó la semana agotado
Igualmente que mi compañero en Madrid ha
sido una semana muy muy movida y pues
esperemos a ver si organizamos todas
estas piezas para darle sentido a lo que
ha sucedido durante la semana bueno a
los dos les pido que por favor me
guarden un poquitico de energía entonces
para poder hacer el programa y hacer un
buen análisis de lo que ha sucedido en
el mundo a lo largo de esta semana
acompáñanos ustedes también con sus
opiniones sus comentarios y sus
preguntas en nuestras redes sociales les
recuerdo que nos encuentran como arroba
franz24
arrobas antilogo que es mi cuenta
personal nuestra etiqueta es numeral una
semana en el mundo f24 todo junto todo
pegado para que dejen ustedes todos los
comentarios pues vamos a comenzar en la
región en donde estamos haciendo
presencia en América Latina porque
preocupa mucho la situación en Perú
hemos sido testigos de semanas de
inestabilidad de enfrentamientos entre
los manifestantes y la policía en Lima
que es la capital del país y también en
diferentes ciudades en el sur del
territorio peruano la presidenta de Perú
Dina boluarte de un mensaje a la nación
en donde rechazó la violencia de los
manifestantes que a lo largo de los
últimos días también viajaron
precisamente desde el sur del país hasta
la capital para realizar la llamada toma
de Lima los manifestantes piden la
renuncia de la presidenta el cierre del
Congreso un llamado a elecciones y
también una asamblea constitucional o
asamblea Constituyente pues comienzo
entonces preguntándole a Roberto Madrid
Esto se está volviendo una crisis
Crónica Todas las semanas estamos
reportando hechos en Perú en torno a
manifestaciones a reclamos hacia el
gobierno y sobre todo pedidos de cambio
en El Ejecutivo y en el legislativo
sí se está volviendo realmente algo que
a mí de verdad me preocupa
Estoy preocupado por esos más de 50
muertos que han fallecido ya en las
protestas sobre todo en el sur del país
donde se han recrudecido más en esa zona
más empobrecida de Perú donde los
ciudadanos Bueno pues se están
manifestando y el gobierno por su parte
la policía está reprimiendo estas
protestas con violencia
con armas Incluso un policía por otro
lado ha sido quemado vivo con lo cual la
escalada de tensión entre los ciudadanos
entre la calle y El poder del gobierno
no deja de crecer estamos viendo una
escalada Día tras día
bueno pues se mantiene en el poder
después de un hecho tan grave como ese
intento de autogolpe de estado como se
le ha catalogado un golpe de estado
técnicamente no se puede ejecutar desde
el propio gobierno por lo que en el
estricto sentido de la palabra no los no
lo sería Pero bautizándolo así después
de esa ese golpe de Pedro Castillo Yo
creo que es urgente que los ciudadanos
decidan que quieren hacer ahora con el
rumbo de su país Dina boluarte por su
parte puede estar hasta abril de 2024 en
el poder y la calle Eso no lo acepta
pero no lo aceptan ni Los partidarios de
Pedro Castillo ni los contrarios a Pedro
Castillo Por lo cual creo que las
protestas están hablando todo el mundo
está pidiendo en Perú unas elecciones
anticipadas y ella por su parte
con lo cual Bueno pues es preocupante
y Camilo su opinión sobre lo que está
sucediendo allí en Perú podemos estar
hablando de una crisis política Crónica
ya se le podría llamar de esa manera
usted cómo lo ve pues Santiago yo yo
Considero que lo que está pasando en
este momento El Perú es la muestra del
fin de algo que se denomina la paradoja
peruana porque durante muchas décadas ha
habido mucha inestabilidad política en
el Perú Pero ha habido estabilidad
económica en este momento estamos viendo
que la crisis política está desbordando
lo que está sucediendo socialmente en el
Perú y claramente hay una inestabilidad
que demuestra una falta de participación
política una falta de los sectores
populares de estar realmente
representados en en las instituciones de
poder Pero lo que yo considero es que lo
que muestra es una completa fractura del
mundo político en el Perú solamente al
volver a pensar que en los últimos seis
años hemos tenido siete presidentes en
el Perú que las sobre todo en el sur del
país no se ven representadas en la clase
política y esa desconexión tan brutal
que hay entre las clases que dirigen el
país y las clases pobres del Perú pues
han llevado a que claramente hay una una
explosión social y una explosión de
crisis política que que la verdad que lo
que va a llevar a a muchos muchos
problemas estructurales en el Perú a
futuro estamos viendo algo muy muy muy
serio claro el problema es estructural y
el problema es de fondo este esta
problemática social y por ejemplo de
infraestructura que haya que no haya una
buena red de hospitales en las regiones
del país y que todos los grandes
tratamientos o tratamientos de alta
complejidad tiene que ser tratados en la
Ciudad de Lima que es la capital eso
entorpece mucho la vida de los
ciudadanos que viven en las provincias
lo mismo con la educación lo mismo con
el transporte pero esos son problemas
que son de largo aliento que el gobierno
de turno o los gobiernos que lleguen en
un futuro tendrán que plantear un de
larga acción y de largo aliento para
poder solucionar ese tipo de problemas
en el momento en el presente en el que
estamos en el tema inmediato y por lo
menos el que yo veo que complica más la
situación es la escalada de violencia en
estos enfrentamientos y en estas
manifestaciones ciudadanas Cómo evitar
que siga muriendo gente en las calles
Camilo Cómo evitar que haya Por fin una
conexión entre el gobierno y los
ciudadanos que tienen todo el derecho de
salir a la calle a reclamar y a
expresarse pero sin destruir las
ciudades y sin atacarse entre ellos
mismos
es que estamos viendo la típica receta
que sucede en otros países de
latinoamérica cuando hay movilizaciones
sociales se criminaliza la protesta
social se les llama terroristas que ha
sido como el gobierno peruano ha
denominado muchos de los manifestantes
copiando estrategias de otros países
pero sobre todo lo que vemos es el uso
de la violencia y de la policía sobre
todo desde la brutalidad policial y los
sexos de la policía para para contener a
los manifestantes que están en su
legítimo derecho de hacer las protestas
lo que en este momento debemos hacer es
es acompañar a la sociedad civil peruana
hacer los procesos de monitoreo de
acompañamiento a lo que está sucediendo
eso es lo principal porque en este
momento estamos viendo lo que se ha
repetido en Colombia Lo que se ha
repetido en Chile en en los años pasados
y es la la brutalidad policial y el
estado claramente criminalizando la
protesta social ahí la sociedad civil
peruana tienen este momento que actuar
acompañar a los manifestantes crear
mecanismos de verificación de lo que
está sucediendo porque en unos tres
cuatro o cinco meses cuando revisemos lo
que lo que ha sucedido en este momento
van a ser vitales para poder reconstruir
lo que ha sucedido estamos hablando de
50 Muertos pero pueden ser más no
sabemos la cantidad desaparecidos no
sabemos puntualmente qué es lo que está
la policía Qué tipo de mecanismos de
violencia o de armas están utilizando
contra la sociedad civil Entonces en
este momento mi invitación es a rodear a
la sociedad civil peruana y sobre todo
hacer acompañamiento lo que está
sucediendo para poder en el futuro
reconstruir realmente lo que pasó y que
no haya impunidad como los casos de
Colombia o de chile en los años pasados
da un poco de tranquilidad Roberto y
Camilo que el congreso peruano
justamente esta semana aprobó la
creación de una comisión para investigar
estos casos de los más de 50 muertos que
ha dejado ya estas manifestaciones Y
estos choques con la policía tienen 90
días para dar algún tipo de respuesta
sobre estas investigaciones vamos a ver
qué arrojan esas pesquisas allí en Perú
Roberto usted se encuentra en la ciudad
de Madrid Al otro lado del Atlántico
para nosotros acá en América Latina
seguimos El Minuto a minuto de lo que
sucede en Perú porque escenarios
similares Ya lo hemos visto algunos
meses atrás en en Bolivia en el país
vecino bueno no hace poco hace mucho
Perdón en Brasil también estaba teniendo
lugar una revuelta en Brasilia lo hemos
visto en diferentes países de la región
Pero cómo se ve esta inestabilidad
política de Perú y de la región desde
España cómo nos ven desde allá
con una enorme preocupación de verdad
con una enorme preocupación Es verdad
que en Europa no hemos visto
afortunadamente Bueno a ningún
presidente Primer Ministro sería
impensable hacer lo que ha hecho Pedro
Castillo con lo cual vimos con los ojos
muy abiertos y con excepción aquel hecho
fatídico para la democracia El Perú y
los posteriores hechos las posteriores
consecuencias que es esta toma de Lima
que se ha producido el jueves estas
protestas que se intensifican ojo Porque
si hay políticos en el caso de España
Bueno pues que han intentado o en su
momento intentaron justificar a Pedro
Castillo e incluso Bueno pues
fundadores de algunos partidos que ya no
están Quizá en la vida activa política
pero que han estado ahí Bueno pues
justificaron aquel auto golpe no eso es
lo que más preocupación causó en España
que pudiera generar y despertar
simpatías todavía la figura de Pedro
Castillo después de lo que ha ocurrido
allí no pero desde luego lo que tenemos
aquí es preocupación por los ciudadanos
al margen del debate político al margen
de esa elevación de ideas y de
discusiones políticas bajemos a tierra
no miremos lo que está pasando en la
calle la economía está destrozada la
gente hay muchas personas que no tienen
que comer y que aún así están saliendo a
la calle porque lo que quieren es el
futuro digno que se merecen Y eso es lo
que vemos con mucha preocupación sin
duda creo que les voy a hacer la
pregunta del millón es difícil de
responder Supongo porque ni yo mismo
tengo algún tipo de respuesta para eso y
he tratado el tema a lo largo de la
semana lo analizamos en el programa del
debate y en los noticieros a lo largo de
la semana ustedes creen que Dina
boluarte termina pronto su mandato o se
mantiene en el poder Roberto para hacer
la ronda la inversa
espero de verdad que termine pronto su
mandato porque es lo que le está
pidiendo la calle las protestas en
cualquier caso
por muy numerosas que seas nunca tienen
no tienen por qué ser un indicador
exacto de Cuál es la soberanía popular
el único indicador Exacto que mide lo
que quiere el pueblo son las urnas por
lo tanto la única forma que ella tendría
o bien justificarse y perpetrarse en el
poder una legislatura más y los peruanos
la eligen o bien dejar su cargo es
convocar elecciones A qué tiene miedo
Por qué no lo hace no Lamentablemente
creo que ella va a seguir ahí ya ha
dicho que están parada por la y
efectivamente en base al derecho
constitucional ella tiene pleno derecho
para agotar la legislatura pero creo que
por dignidad política y por dignidad
democrática debería consultar Cuál es el
deseo de los peruanos eso por la por la
dignidad de ella como política y también
de la Democracia pero Perú puede
soportar otra caída de otro presidente
otra elección de otro presidente como lo
vio usted Roberto y ya le doy la palabra
a Camilo
yo creo que sería la forma de acabar con
las protestas y de traer un gobierno que
genere estabilidad Dina boluarte lo que
ha demostrado es incapacidad e inacción
esas dos cosas yo creo con lo cual no es
una figura que genere consenso no es una
figura que despierte simpatías y por lo
tanto creo que mediante la Constitución
de un nuevo gobierno votado elegido
democráticamente por los peruanos
podríamos entrar en un periodo de
estabilidad bueno eso se pensaba con
Pedro castillo y miré en el escenario en
el que estamos Roberto es es muy
paradójico el caso de Perú Camilo qué
piensa usted termina boluarte su mandato
cae pronto termina
renuncia hay una un llamado a elecciones
pues Santiago yo estaba revisando
algunas cifras antes de venir acá al
programa y leía como el instituto de
estudios peruanos hizo un estudio Hace
en estos días diciendo que solo tres de
diez peruanos aprueba el gobierno de
boluarte y que claramente no en ella una
figura política legítima para el país Yo
creo que en este momento es un momento
clave y puntual para hacer un nuevo
pacto político y social en el Perú Yo
creo que la presidente boluarte tiene en
este momento que que renunciar tiene que
convocar a elecciones pero sobre todo
tiene que generar un proceso que logre
generar un nuevo pacto político y social
entre la ciudadanía y y la clase
gobernante del Perú porque no podemos
tener cada seis meses un presidente
nuevo pero sobre todo lo problemático es
que no hay una estabilidad política que
conduzca a una construcción social Real
de lo del Perú yo creo que hay un
momento histórico en este momento hay
una oportunidad yo creo que las
protestas en este momento están
mostrando esa oportunidad Y esa ventana
de oportunidad para generar un nuevo
pacto social y político Ojalá esta
señora esté a la altura histórica y eso
es lo que yo creo que le va a demandar
la ciudadanía Y nosotros a futuro si
ella va a tener la dignidad política la
claridad política de aprovechar este
momento y realmente dar un paso al
costado y volver a barajar todo y ojalá
generar un proceso político de largo
aliento en el Perú me gusta que usted
vea esa ventana de oportunidad yo en mi
caso lo veo más como que se aproximan
más al final del callejón en donde se
cierra el escenario no soy tan optimista
porque hay otro factor que hay que tener
en cuenta Camilo y es el Congreso que es
pieza clave en todo este rompecabezas
político de Perú y la población también
está pidiendo la renuncia de El Congreso
completo y piden unas elecciones para
renovarlo pero el congreso parece estar
completamente atornillado en el poder
difícil lidiar con los legisladores
peruanos que intentan es Buscar maneras
de legislar a su favor para precisamente
permanecer en el poder
Sí por supuesto y lo vemos sobre todo en
los movimientos Campesinos de los
ronderos cuando en Arequipa y en puno
salían precisamente a pedir el cierre
del Congreso y la renovación del
Congreso o sea yo creo que ahí también
una responsabilidad muy grande de los
legisladores peruanos de acompañar este
nuevo proceso de renovación política
pero claramente lo que está demostrando
es que el congreso peruano no está a la
altura de lo que está sucediendo y por
el contrario están Sencillamente
siguiendo y reproduciendo ese racismo y
ese clasismo histórico que tiene a la
clase gobernante del Perú en este
momento en la crisis y aquí ha provocado
esta crisis Bueno pues lo que esté
sucediendo en Perú lo que vaya
sucediendo a lo largo de estos días
seguirá siendo noticia aquí en France 24
por supuesto seguimos con la lupa puesta
en este país suramericano rápidamente
para el cierre Roberto qué podemos estar
viendo para los próximos días lo digo en
el programa del debate no tenemos la
bola de cristal no tenemos aquí el juego
de naipes de cartas para ver el futuro
Pero qué podría pasar en Perú ya hemos
visto siempre pensamos que hemos visto
todo lo posible políticamente hablando
en este país y vuelve y empieza un
capítulo distinto con un escenario
diferente y uno dice Bueno A dónde nos
lleva ahora la situación
sí totalmente Pues yo creo que
lamentablemente espero de verdad Ojalá
equivocarme en mi proyección de lo que
va a ocurrir allí pero bueno pues
vaticina una escalada de tensión
probablemente se den más muertes y un
estallido Quién sabe hasta qué punto No
Espero que no se lleve a un estallido
civil pero la verdad es que este país
está totalmente dividido ahora mismo
ensangrentado y esto si viene a boluarte
sigue con la actitud que tiene hoy en
día Pues solo puede ir a más y para
Camilo qué podemos ver en los próximos
días yo creo que se vienen unos días de
más violencia por parte del Estado yo
creo que en este momento está claro que
el estado está utilizando toda su fuerza
y los próximas semanas van a ser
cruciales y en eso invito a la
ciudadanía peruana que por favor se
proteja porque lo que se viene es la
escalada total de violencia como como lo
vemos en las en las secuencias que de
otros países y después de esa fuerte
violencia yo creo que va a haber un
momento en el la comunidad internacional
va a tener que actuar O sea no podemos
dejar que esto suceda yo sí quiero ver y
eso es como la lo que predigo que una
predicción es que en algún momento
Colombia Bolivia Ecuador los países
latinoamericanos tienen que intervenir y
yo lo que veo es esa otra ventana de
oportunidad pero yo espero lo que veo es
una escalada de violencia mucho más
fuerte en los días siguientes Y a partir
de eso una una participación de la
comunidad latinoamericana para encontrar
una solución pero pero el camino se ve
muy complicado se ve muy complicado pues
ahí ven dos escenarios posibles de esta
crisis de Perú por supuesto la vamos a
estar analizando aquí en France 24
pasemos a otro tema destacado de la
semana porque en un mes de septiembre
pero del año 2017 dábamos justamente
esta noticia en France 24 porque fue un
hecho que sin quererlo empezó a darle la
vuelta al mundo y empezó a tomar fuerza
en las portadas y en los medios de
comunicación eran unas elecciones en un
país en el Pacífico Sur en Nueva Zelanda
que llevaron al triunfo a una joven de
solamente 37 años en ese momento era
entonces la dirigente más joven del
mundo a esa juventud y a esa energía se
le sumó ser la primera líder de un país
que daba a luz en medio de su mandato la
jacindamanía se estaba tomando ya el
mundo entero cautivó al planeta entero y
justamente esta semana Hacienda arden
anunció que no aspirará a su reelección
y a mantenerse en el cargo de primera
ministra de Nueva Zelanda después de
estar cinco años liderando ese país del
Pacífico Sur arden tuvo un liderazgo
bastante empático firme Y tuvo momentos
muy decisivos Como por ejemplo el
atentado en la ciudad de christores la
erupción del volcán wakari me perdonará
mi maorí que no es muy fluido la gestión
de la pandemia de Kobe 19 y también el
plan de recuperación económica de ese
importante economía para
El Pacífico La Premier neozelandesa ha
dicho que está agotada y contrario a
varios mandatos que vemos Que
mandatarios Perdón que intentan
aferrarse al poder esta pues puso por
encima su salud su tranquilidad y dijo
estoy agotada me retiro y
de un mensaje muy claro sobre una
problemática social que muchos vivimos
el burn out que pasa factura por el
exceso de trabajo y por la falta de
descanso le doy la palabra a Roberto
para comenzar la ronda la inversa sobre
algún balance de lo que deja jacindarden
en Nueva Zelanda un país que podemos
verlo muy lejano desde la realidad
latinoamericana Pero pero esta primera
ministra logró darle una visibilidad
internacional bastante Clara y y nos
deja varias lecciones
totalmente Es verdad que ella ha
demostrado Bueno pues ser una mujer con
una gran capacidad de Liderazgo creo que
sale del poder en este caso dando una
lección de humanidad vemos como por
primera vez un político se humaniza a
veces Parece que son extraterrestres no
pero son como todos nosotros y ella ha
dicho soy humana no tengo energía por lo
tanto basta lo que sí que he observado
en estos cinco años que ha estado ella
en el cargo es que llegó con unos
índices de popularidad muy altos en todo
el mundo y sin embargo deja un país con
una situación un poco complicada con un
gran hartazgo social y a su partido en
particular lo deja con unos índices de
popularidad muy bajos los más bajos
desde 2017 ya las encuestas no las daban
no la daban a ella como ganadora de los
próximos comicios que se celebran dentro
de nueve meses por tanto él quien dice
que quizá esa salida adelantada también
se puede deber Bueno pues a evitar un
fracaso en las urnas no en cualquier
caso el argumento ya es muy humano muy
legítimo Pero qué deja una inflación al
7,2%, una subida de los tipos de interés
enorme y un aumento del precio de la
gasolina una situación económica muy
complicada que no es un caso particular
de Nueva Zelanda sino que afecta un poco
a todo accidente
Tal parece que la economía está
recuperación económica es la gran
factura que le pasa a ella la sociedad
neozelandesa y también la oposición
había mucha presión por parte de los
partidos de oposición y por eso
ya algunos analistas hablaban de una
alternancia en el poder su partido
laborista Salía del poder para darle
paso a otra formación política después
de esta administración de cinco años
Camilo su opinión su balance
Pues yo creo que yesinda muestra como un
polo puesto lo que sucedió en el 2017 si
recordamos Trump llegó a la casa blanca
en Estados Unidos en 2017 y yesinda
llegó como Primer Ministro en Nueva
Zelanda del mismo año y y muestran los
dos Polos opuestos de cómo la política
puede ser emocional y no burocrática
porque los dos generan muchos
muchas emociones y yo creo que en el
caso de yessin es muy interesante porque
ella logró tener ese tipo de política de
la empatía y de la bondad que que
Santiago estaba diciendo muy
acertadamente pero que logro pero que
sobre todo logra Mostrar que el mundo
político sigue siendo muy masculino que
sigue siendo muy patriarcal y que ella
lo que está demostrando es Cómo lograr
generar una política diferente desde la
empatía desde la sensibilidad hay que
recordar que el tratamiento que ella
hizo en el ataque terrorista de de la
masacre de Chris Church fue fue
magistral porque fue ponerse en el lugar
de lo otro porque fue hacer unos
procesos de bondad y de empatía con las
con las víctimas y sobre todo comprender
mucho más allá Desde el humano y no
desde lo políticamente ideológico lo que
está sucediendo y yo creo que ya nos
está mostrando nos mostró en su en
durante su mandato una nueva dimensión
de la política desde un feminismo mucho
más centrado en la bondad la empatía
pero sobre todo nos mostraba mucho más
que la política se puede hacer de unas
formas emocionales mucho más
interesantes y no tan burocráticas
claramente le han pasado se ha pasado
cobro y es y es muy interesante también
recordar que haya sido durante todo su
tiempo completamente atacada ha sido
digamos muy criticada por las políticas
que que hubo sobre todo en el
confinamiento con el covid
todos los grupos
antibacunas hicieron campañas contra
ella muy fuertes Igualmente todo lo que
pasó después de Chris George con la con
las políticas que intentó hacer para
controlar las armas Entonces digamos que
ella navegó en unas aguas muy
turbulentas pero también muestra que que
fue una persona que que fue muy muy
golpeada y muy criticada en las redes
sociales y que Obviamente le pasó
factura al final pero yo creo que ella
nos muestra una dimensión de la política
yo creo interesante a futuro Yo creo que
coincido con ustedes dos coincido con
Camilo en que este atentado en Chris
George fue un punto de quiebre de su
imagen a nivel internacional nos mostró
una política muy cercana a una sociedad
sobre todo porque lo comparo con otros
países donde suceden ataques similares
claro Nueva Zelanda es un país
supremamente Pacífico este tipo de
ataques son una gran eventualidad en esa
sociedad pero pero esa esa conexión que
tuvo ella con los ciudadanos con los
familiares de las víctimas y el
tratamiento que le dio a la crisis pues
es completamente distinto y opuesto a lo
que sucede por ejemplo en Estados Unidos
donde cada dos por tres hay una masacre
en una escuela en una universidad o en
una calle y el presidente o Los Altos
políticos del país no muestran ningún
tipo de empatías y con la sociedad y el
tema Ya prácticamente se volvió parte de
la realidad y de la cotidianidad
ya lo reportamos cada tanto este tipo de
masacres ella le dio un manejo muy
distinto y creo que ahí fue cuando ella
tuvo ese esa explosión a nivel
internacional y empezó a llamar aún más
la atención un tema importante habiendo
ya analizado los diferentes puntos
positivos y negativos de su mandato
importante ver también la razón por la
que se va por estar cansada Dice ella
que está agotada que no tiene energía y
que el cargo de primera ministra demanda
estará al 100% y que ya no lo puede
estar el Brown out que es
estar completamente agotado por el
exceso de trabajo personalmente lo he
vivido es muy difícil hacer frente a la
situación sobre todo porque coincide que
en ese momento te llega más trabajo y es
cuando más tienes que responder y es
cuando menos energía tienes una realidad
del Siglo 21 y de esta sociedad Camilo
le cómo lo lleva usted
No pues pues los llevo digamos que no
con la con la con la tranquilidad que
quisiera yo creo que que también eso
demuestra las crisis profundas de del
trabajo contemporáneo o sea yo creo que
le que lo que reivindicó sin ser
completamente fan de de de que tuvo por
lo menos la honestidad de decir que
estaba cansada y tenía por lo menos la
oportunidad de salir hay muchas personas
que que por no tienen el privilegio para
hacer eso entonces también hay que
recordar un poquito como también desde
lo femenino se busca pensarse eso del
privilegio de otras formas ella tuvo la
oportunidad Después de cinco años y
medio estar en el poder en Nueva Zelanda
decir ya paro estoy burnound estoy
cansada pero cuántas personas en
Latinoamérica y en otras partes del
mundo no tiene la posibilidad de
renunciar y les toca seguir trabajando
por eso entonces también como
reflexionar sobre las políticas del
cuidado de cómo el capitalismo nos está
devorando como el trabajo nos está
devorando y son Sencillamente las
expresiones de este caníbal como lo
dicen muchos analistas de que nos está
consumiendo en las formas de trabajo que
que no Debería ser y cómo ve uno también
Camilo algunos mandatarios
latinoamericanos completamente quemados
burn out sin energía pero que quieren
seguir Solo por tener el poder en la
mano Roberto su opinión sobre este tema
que creo que a todos nos ha golpeado de
una u otra manera sobre todo a los
periodistas que no paramos llevamos
cuatro años entre pandemia Guerra y
Ucrania no hemos parado
en la actualidad Mira yo recuerdo la
primera redacción en la que trabajé
cuando empezaba observé que los
periodistas veteranos Bueno pues sus
parejas eran periodistas también o eran
camarógrafos o eran bueno algo dentro
del sector no Y entonces una jefa Me
dijo Mira Robert si vas a ser periodista
tienes que estar con alguien que
entienda la entrega 24 horas
O sea que Efectivamente es así es un
hecho pero por encima del periodismo la
política es sin duda el sector en el que
más desgaste se Provo sufren los
políticos de cualquier espectro
ideológico una campaña de desprestigio
continua un bombardeo absoluto un
cuestionamiento de cada cosa que hacen
cada cosa que dicen una auditoría
intensiva de cada gesto cada mirada
claro eso agota no y al margen de ese
agotamiento la política en Sí al margen
de ese agotamiento personal también hay
un desgaste de la figura pública no de
la imagen que proyecta ese político en
todos no se me ocurre ningún líder
político que haya estado en un largo
periodo de tiempo en el poder y no haya
acabado con unos índices de popularidad
bajos en el caso de España Pues pienso
en Felipe González Por ejemplo
expresidente que
tras ganar con mayoría absoluta varias
elecciones se fue por la puerta de atrás
pienso También en margaret thatcher no
son casos muy muy muy diferentes al que
este del que estamos hablando pero que
reflejan ese desgaste político no se
puede prolongar porque es una una
actividad en fin trae consigo un enorme
incluso diría acoso no mediático y por
parte de la ciudadanía por otro lado
tiene su pleno derecho y los periodistas
tenemos el pleno derecho también de
observar y vigilar
coincido coincido con ese desgaste de la
figura política coincido con ese
desgaste de la estructura del Estado
Bueno lo vemos en Perú la gente está
cansada de las figuras políticas que hay
de los parlamentarios que hay hay un
desgaste si ven todos los temas van
ligados uno con el otro aquí en una
semana en el mundo vamos llegando ya al
bloque final de el programa pasamos a un
tema bastante interesante porque este
domingo 2 de enero china celebra el año
nuevo comienza entonces oficialmente el
año del conejo de agua de acuerdo a la
tradición de ese país asiático es
oficialmente ese día el primer día de
ese nuevo año de acuerdo al calendario
lunar y para ello sería el inicio del
año
4721 nos llevan bastante ventaja en el
conteo de los de los años es tal vez la
festividad más importante de China
millones de personas se desplazan a sus
regiones de origen esto es catalogado
como la migración humana más grande del
mundo Cada año la celebración tiene
lugar en medio de una ola de repuntes de
casos de covid-19 y hay una preocupación
por ese después que va a suceder después
de esa celebración a nivel sanitario a
nivel hospitalario cuando pasa esta
festividad y el Kobe 19 haga de las
suyas el gobierno en Beijing ha dicho
que lo peor de la ola ya pasó y que los
chinos pueden ir a celebrar tranquilo su
año nuevo pero también queremos hablar
precisamente del año nuevo hablar de las
supersticiones de ese lado más Místico y
más mágico que trae el año nuevo chino
que comienza el año del conejo de agua
como lo estaba diciendo Roberto primero
Comencemos por el lado serio del tema y
es esta pandemia de Kobe 19 que no
termina esta ola que podemos estar
viendo en los próximos días en China con
esta gigantesca movilización de personas
hacia sus ciudades de origen Bueno pues
ha sido terrorífico de verdad lo que han
vivido en China yo conozco gente que
está viviendo en China y que lo ha
pasado muy mal con esa política covicero
que se ha levantado tres años después
poco a poco el fin ha costado así bien
levantar la mano para que los ciudadanos
pues respiren un poco de libertad de
nuevo Así que tienen muchas ganas de
celebración Eso es lo que me dice la
gente que está viviendo allí los chinos
este año para ellos es muy especial lo
quieren celebrar por todo lo alto pero
son conscientes también del riesgo que
trae una Nueva Ola una nueva variante la
variante Kraken España ya ha tomado
restricciones respecto a Los viajeros
que provengan de China y eso que
prácticamente todas las restricciones
estaban ya levantadas Bueno pues ahora
se han Interpuesto contra los ciudadanos
que vengan de este país por el riesgo de
que traigan más casos de coronavirus no
así que lo van a vivir con efusividad y
también con preocupación y Camilo su
opinión Yo creo que se viene un momento
muy interesante entre la relación de los
ciudadanos chinos con el gobierno chino
porque hay que recordar que las
protestas que parte digamos que la gente
pueda ahorita disfrutar el año nuevo
viene porque muchas personas se
movilizaron contra estas contra Pues los
las encerronas y los bloqueos que hizo
el Gobierno chino para controlar el la
expansión del covid 19 en China ese
acero tolerancias al covid y mucha gente
salió a la calle a protestar y muchos
analistas coinciden en que en este
momento la gente puede viajar gracias a
que el chino dijo un momento diviértanse
en un poco y pueden salir y disfruten el
año nuevo pero también hay como una
consecuencia de esa movilización
ciudadana que es muy extraña que suceda
en un gobierno autoritario capitalista
como es el chino o sea eso es eso da una
puntada que va a ser muy interesante al
futuro como el covid ha generado
movilización ciudadana en China y cómo
eso después del año nuevo creo que puede
abrir también una oportunidad para que
los ciudadanos chinos empiecen a
demandar otro tipo de cosas al gobierno
y que de alguna manera es hermetismo Y
esa digamos que esa manera como se
controla la ciudadanía en China puedo
empezar a desquebrajarse y yo creo que
eso puede ser algo futuro interesante de
ver cómo la ciudadanía puede encontrar
de nuevo una oportunidad para para
buscar más libertad y no vivir en un
gobierno autoritario como el que en el
que vive renovar esa relación entre el
estado y el ciudadano a partir de esas
manifestaciones que han sido las más
grandes hasta el momento bueno por lo
menos en la historia reciente de ese
país
coincide Este término de renovación
coincide precisamente con el año del
conejo el año del conejo significa sanar
aliviar reformular cambio hay una
renovación completa tal vez coincidan y
se conjuguen todos esos esos diferentes
aspectos y le permite a los chinos
entablar un tipo de relación distinta
con su estado ustedes son supersticiosos
creen en esto de el año de El Conejo Yo
sé que pues Debe de haber celebrado el
año nuevo hace ya varios días atrás
Obviamente con sus respectivos
amuletos y supersticiones pero cuéntenos
si creen en este tipo de de partes y más
Mística de la cultura china
Camilo
yo no no creo en supersticiones
obviamente por por ser colombiano y
haber vivido en una en un contexto
católico
conservador en Colombia obviamente
muchas tradiciones que que se dan sobre
todo ligados a la a la religión católica
pero en general no no no creo mucho en
supervisiones pero sí Considero que hay
ciclos en la vida claro
pero sí creo que que la vida hay ciclos
y hay que renovarse en algún momento
Roberto rápidamente por favor muy
puntual
Bueno yo intuyo que 2023 va a ser el año
del cambio como trae el conejo creo que
el conejo nos va a traer bendiciones y
tengo una Superstición que son las 12
uvas para mí el año nuevo son las 12
uvas me las tengo que tomar cada inicio
de año y bueno en la tradición china
Pues también es bonita
la Feliz año nuevo a todos los chinos
Pues a Roberto de Camilo les agradezco
por haber estado con nosotros aquí en
una semana en el mundo ustedes pueden
seguir en sintonía de France 24 siga con
nosotros
[Música]